[Applause]
thank you so much for that incredible
introduction and good evening ladies and
gentlemen I'm very excited to be here
this evening with such an incredible
panel of distinguished guests and I
think we're going to have a really
interesting conversation about what is
undoubtedly an incredibly important
topic and this issue of how much
attention and how much coverage to give
terrorists and how much time to spend
discussing terrorism is something that I
think a lot of us have thought about as
my as being a journalist myself who has
covered many terrorist attacks it is
something I have often grappled with are
we part of the solution are we part of
the problem how much is too much
certainly it's something we can't ignore
but are we spending too much time on it
or as president Donald Trump has
suggested are we not covering it enough
so there are a lot of different
viewpoints on this uh on this topic and
that's why we're so lucky to have this
incredible panel the official title of
tonight's debate is don't give them what
they want terrorists should be starved
of the oxygen of publicity and I should
say we're not going to do this as a sort
of strict formal debate tonight but what
I will do is take a show of hands in the
beginning of the evening and then uh at
the end of the evening as well so we can
get a feel for how people's thought
thoughts has changed as the evening um
has progressed and of course after we
hear from all of our incredible speakers
uh in about 45 minutes time we'll open
up the floor for Q&A so that you can
also uh pick some of these Incredible
Minds so without further Ado let me
begin to introduce our incredible panel
I start here with to my left Simon
Jenkins who is of course uh one of the
UK's leading commentators he was the
editor of the evening standard the
editor of the times was chairman of the
National Trust he still writes a column
weekly for the guardian and also for the
evening standard and you can see him
often on the BBC and of course he writes
a lot about this topic of terrorism and
National Security issues in general next
we have FZ jeris who is a frequent guest
on
CNN um we're privileged to have him he
is a professor of international
relations at the lsse and really he is
one of the world's foremost experts on
this issue of Jihadi terrorism and he
has written a couple of incredible books
on this topic one of which I'm just
going to shamelessly plug right now a
history of Isis if you haven't read it
I'm being serious and sincere it's an
excellent book um and he is also written
another very good book about the rise
and fall of al-Qaeda and last but
certainly not least we have Douglas
Murray who is the associate editor at
The Spectator uh he is also a
best-selling author and an award-winning
political commentator he focuses
particularly on the UK and the us but
also on issues of foreign policy
terrorism National Security and the
Middle East so you've got a lot of brain
power going on here tonight um so what
I'd like to do right now before we have
our opening comments is to get a share
uh a sort of show of hands from you guys
as to where what your thinking is on
this so uh those who agree with the
motion that terrorists should be starved
of the oxygen of publicity can you put
up your hands those who
agree
okay all right that's a that's a pretty
big chunk okay that's interesting and
now can I ask those who disagree to put
up their
hands so it looks like the uh supporters
of the motion are in the majority at
this stage yeah okay and and those who
don't
know
okay a minority so well I'm sure
everyone's going to have a very firm
opinion by the time we finished hearing
from our guests um so let me start now
with you Simon if you would like to give
your opening remarks I think if you
believe that the terrorist should be
starved of the oxygen of publicity why
are you
here um the the uh the the my point of
view for what it's worth is that I don't
think terrorism is very important um and
I think we make it important um and by
making it important we make it important
uh it does not matter very much uh a
terrorist incident is is a happening
it's an accident it affects the people
directly in affected by it um but
terrorism does not threaten States it
doesn't threaten the Integrity of
America or Britain um they can't invade
us um they can't do serious damage to
our economy unless we let them they
cannot affect our values our democracy
anything like that unless we let them um
they are they are to all intents and
purposes useless criminals they simply
blow things up and kill people uh the
only point at which they threaten us is
by our reaction to them they have no
standing whatsoever other than in terms
of our reaction to them and our reaction
to them is conditioned by the publicity
we give them uh they depend upon
publicity the multiplier of publicity is
what makes the terrorism act terrorist
otherwise it's just a killing that's why
very few terrorist incidents occur in
autocratic and dictatorial countries
they don't get any publicity they get
publicity where we give them publicity
and it's on that publicity that they
feed uh Isis interesting last week said
they regard publicity as their nuclear
weapon it's the thing they rely upon to
make their impact uh we've become
completely obsessed with them terrorism
has been seized upon by the military
defense establishment um effectively to
boost their budgets terrorists should be
dealt with by by crime Watchers by
police by intelligence agents and so on
they're not a source of of aircraft
carriers or bombers uh all that sort of
thing um we have gone far too far in
reacting to them and Donald Trump who
sooner or later will be mentioned this
evening um illustrates that so well by
saying we should give them more
publicity what a lunatic thing to do I
simply think that the best thing we can
possibly do is you cannot not cover news
and I'm sure tonight we'll discuss what
this really means you can't not cover
news uh you then hand the terrorist over
to the much more terrorist thing which
is the rumor you mustn't allow rumor to
dominate news but we mustn't overe
exaggerate the significance of a
terrorist incident
um the BBC spent four days on the nce
atrocity um Obama comes over to march in
honor of the um the hebo massacres it
was an appalling way of glorifying this
particular obscenity I feel so strongly
that the least we could do to publicize
terrorists the more we're likely to
defeat them I just have to ask you
though you mentioned you say terrorism
doesn't threaten states do you I mean it
may not affect or threaten directly
Western States but if you look at at
middle eastern states or Iraq for
example it seems that Isis got pretty
far in challenging their power Isis is
is an
Insurgency terrorism is a mechanism it's
not an ideology terrorism is a form of
attack uh you you you you try and kill
people you try and cause an atrocity in
order to terrify someone to change them
get them to change their mind or change
their policy um Isis is an Insurgency
which is occupying territory now that's
a completely different matter from
terrorism they happen to use terrorist
methods but they're not their Essence is
not terrorism their Essence is the
setting up of a cipit so I mean I I come
back to my point there's no point in
terrorism if you don't give it publicity
okay for was well I uh I'm going to
probably I I agree to a great extent
with Simon but I before I do so in the
debate I I want to I have two points in
terms of context uh the first point is
that one of the lessons I have learned
over really the last 20 years was
working on these groups we call them
social
movements uh social movement that use
violence for political purposes one of
the lessons is that whether you're
talking about alqa or Isis they're
waging two battles one battle on the
battlefield to carry out attacks whether
in Iraq or Syria or Libya or Egypt or
Istanbul and one battle is really for
the hearts on mind one battle for to get
publicity they crave publicity in fact I
would argue and eyes in the eyes of
whether it was Usama Bin Laden or Abu
Bak bagdadi the greater Jihad is not to
carry out attacks the greater Jihad is
to get more publicity to get the reason
why publicity and coverage is very
important because it's a force
multiplier and there are three reasons
why publicity matters coverage matters
first they want to basically uh trigger
fear uh I mean the institution of
terrorism as you've said it's all about
fear U it's about really creating Fe
fears instilling fear terrorizing the
enemy and also about inspiring and
motivating the base they want to
motivate the base whether it's in Iraq
or Afghanistan or even some of the
deluded young man in Western societies
and they also as a potential recruitment
technique so when CNN and BBC and all of
us go and talk about the attacks in
Paris or Brussels or this is basically
feeds into their narrative they matter
they matter greatly they have the
capacity to terrorize Western Society
in fact many of us now focus on Isis
somehow Isis has invented uh the
so-called social media let's remember
that it was Usama bin ladan who
pioneered the strategy of really
appealing to the media he turned his
humble cave in Afghanistan into a
meeting room where basically worldclass
I mean uh reporters visited his cave in
Afghanistan let's remember Peter Bergen
of the CNN Robert Fisk of the
independent ABD atwan and many other
others in fact in the eyes of us B Laden
the media was it he wants to spread his
message he wants to basically get his
message near and far not only to Muslim
audiences but also to certain
constituency in the west so we need when
we talk about coverage regardless that
this is plays into their own narrative
it matters a great deal they crave
publicity the second point in terms of
context I want to and I want to come
back to Simon's point I mean what we
need to take I mean into account
again if we take all the terrorist
attacks uh that have taken place since
the mid 1990s terrorism does not
represent a strategic threat terrorism
basically represents a limited nuisance
limited nuisance um it's so sad and
tragic when you have the Prime Minister
Britain David Cameron saying Isis
represents an existential threat to the
West Isis represents an existential
threat to the West well the hell with
the West if Isis really threatened the
West think about it uh the same thing
with I mean Donald Trump now he
criticized the American Media for not
covering I mean terrorism enough again
you have now Western leaders who are
using terrorism as a political tool as a
a and to come back to the argument that
terrorism really represents a limited
nuisance as opposed to a strategic
threat I mean look what since 9 11 the
average annual on between 19 between
2001 and 2015 we estimate that only six
individuals have been killed in the
United States and the United Kingdom in
incidents related to islamist Terror
annually you're talking about six
individuals who have been killed in the
United States and the UK as a result of
terrorist incident we know that
basically lightning in the United States
kills 30 people annually we know
hundreds of people get killed as a
result of deer causing incidents um in
Ohio itself nine people die every day as
a result of doses high doses again we
need to keep I'm not suggesting that
terrorism is not Insidious is not
dangerous but what I'm trying to say is
that too much publicity basically plays
into the narrative vies final point I'm
not suggesting we should not cover
terrorism because terrorism matters to
it's a it's a newsworthy uh thing it
matters a great deal it should be
proportional it should be we should put
it in perspective we should have
resilience and the final Point by really
I mean overplaying inflating terrorism
we are terrorizing
ourselves this is really what this is so
you're not advocating for sort of self
censorship but you're saying that media
coverage should be more responsible more
nuanced and there should be less of it
absolutely and we sh we should tell the
audience about I mean the effects of
terrorism the impact of terrorism as
opposed to you know more than I do how
many days we have spent on the I mean
terrorist attacks in Paris or Brussels
they were horrible they were Insidious
they were dangerous but it was a kind of
I mean playing Into The Narrative of
Isis and alqaeda and Aran Peninsula
giving them ammunition providing them
with the oxygen this is their greater
Jihad
because they appeal to the base we are
invincible we are undefeatable we are
bleeding the West terrorizing the West
in a way it's the oxygen that sustains
The Narrative and again we are
terrorizing our incidents final point I
know we come back to it let me turn the
table on its head and say we're talking
about whether terrorism provides oxygen
to groups like Al and Isis let me say
that as a result of this Obsession in
fact our coverage and obsession with
terrorism we are providing oxygen to
populist movement in Western societies
we are distorting domestic politics in
the West in fact this obsession with
this kind of limited threat is providing
oxygen to hyper you know farri movements
and in many ways it's really changing
dramatically transforming Western
politics not just playing Into The
Narrative of Isis and alqa okay Douglas
are you going to jump in to the rescue
of Western
media not likely
um um thank you great pleasure to be
having very glad this isn't a debate
format because I think this question is
so complex and I think most of us have
such um contrary views were on this it's
very good thing that it's not set up as
an either or thing um first thing I I
would say but I agree very much with
what faras just said about uh that
Cameron point I I entirely agree I
thought it was an absurd uh indeed
obscene thing for prime minister of the
UK to say that Isis is an existential
threat uh when it's no such thing
however I do have to point back push
back a little on something that Simon
has already said um terrorism can do
serious damage and as everybody knows
just from that one thing that's already
come up twice this evening the attacks
in Paris in November 2015 it still is
doing damage still Parisian economy the
tourist economy has not recovered from
that it's still a city suffering from
that now I don't know how you could get
into a situation where multiple suicide
bombings go off in our nearest the
nearest Capital City to this one where
multiple suicide bombings go off at a
football match at a rock venue drive by
shootings kashik off attacks in cafes
and restaurants and that wasn't reported
or it just was mentioned and we all got
on with our lives the public want to to
know that information we want to know
I'm going to go to Paris next weekend is
it a wise idea is it is it is it good to
go or not of course we need this
information and we need the media to be
reporting it and I have to say that we
have to appreciate what the end point of
Simon's uh uh uh point of view on this
is in 2013 when two British converts to
Islam two very radical young men uh
beheaded ran over in broad daylight in
South London in this city ran over uh a
soldier at home on leave from
Afghanistan Ral Rigby hacked at his body
in the middle of the road tried to get
his head off with machetes and so on
Simon described that as a mundane act of
violence now I don't think that is
mundane act it was in your guardian
column at the time
sorry anyhow it it it was a mundane act
of
violence but you see for most most of us
the general public we don't think that
the reporting of a soldier being
decapitated in broad daylight by two
such men is a mundane thing it is
certainly an act of violence but we have
to be very careful that is that is the
end point of dismissing the terrorists
of saying we don't give them any Oxygen
we we we try to um to to get around it
in some way now I think by the way that
ter that the censorship around terrorism
already exists to an enormous extent in
our societies the media in this country
and in America and elsewhere don't show
anything like explicit images of the
aftermaths of terrorist attacks and
there is a very good argument that
actually if the public saw what those of
us who've covered and seen attacks have
seen that their views on this would be a
lot harder than they currently are and
that the media actually holds this back
from the public and that as a result the
public are less uh um enraged than they
would otherwise be by this but you know
if if you support the motion tonight uh
how would you do it how would you stop
covering the terrorists when they carry
out an attack in Paris for night and
kill 130 people and leave many more
wounded for the rest of their lives how
would you do it how would you do it in
the age of the
internet okay it's plausible you could
get a press regulatory body uh so
rigorous that it stopped the remainder
of the print press from publishing any
information about it people would go to
the Internet how do you shut down the
internet from covering this now having
said that there there's one very
important point on this which is that
obviously the Press have to show
restraint and I want to give you two
very quick examples uh in my life of the
press clearly not showing restraint on
this and this is where there will be
some unanimity on the panel tonight in
2004 when the British born uh uh man Ken
bigley was held hostage in Iraq by abam
muab Al Zak's group uh many of you will
remember this there was a drip drip feed
of information on an hourly and daily
basis by Zak's group and they knew and
we knew from the moment that American
forces ended up getting into his
compound that his group were watching
the British media like Hawks because
Tony Blair was being personally held
responsible by a man being held hostage
with a knife to his throat and if you
remember that man Ken bigley was saying
on camera I blame Tony Blair and the
British press were blaming Tony Blair
and there was a moment there where the
combination of a a a an extremist group
and the British press effectively
helping them could well have brought
down a prime minister in a Democratic
Society came very very close at that
point and the second example I would
give was 10 years after that in 2014
when uh jih had John uh as he was called
Muhammad awazi another British citizen
was uh executing murdering beheading
people in the Syrian desert I would
argue that was another time when the
British press needed to show show
restraint and a lot of it did you'll
remember that the independent ran a
front page saying that we are not
showing the photo of this that may have
been an extreme example but the British
press once again on that occasion the
international press were being used by
that group to have this drum beat of
Terror so on that I think there'll be
some agreement I think that the British
press by and large does show restraint I
don't think we canot cover the
terrorists but there are occasions when
the press in this country and elsewhere
has got it very badly wrong well so let
me ask you you know you bring up jih
John and I think this is an interesting
one why why why give him a nickname like
Jihadi John why not call him by his name
Muhammad anazi why do we have to come up
the very idea of coming up with
nicknames and also I wanted to ask you
about a distinction between covering
Isis propaganda and terrorist attacks
there's a big difference between running
their videos of them with the black and
white flag saying the shahada and
showing what happened in Paris right yes
there is there's a very big difference
between the two and sometimes we fall
into covering both as if if they were
the same thing um but as as for that the
nickname point is a very good point I'm
uh slightly beused by it myself uh of
course we didn't know his name was
Muhammad mwasi when we knew that he
existed and he was the the decapitator
so he had to be given some term I
suppose I do think that the sort of
weird jok of it is the Beatles we we I
think coined the term in the British
press I I don't know why people do it
it's maybe it's a coping mechanism about
something very grotesque and that you
can sort of slightly laugh at it I don't
know it it doesn't seem very healthy to
me I've always thought that it
familiarizes
barbarism so let me let me ask you Simon
and we'll we'll sort of have a bit more
of a fluid chat now but you know I mean
what you're essentially talking about
amounts to self-censorship on on a
certain level and I just wonder does it
confuse the role of the journalist at
all because the journalist traditionally
is not supposed to to be a judge the
journalist is supposed to be someone who
is a filter who provides information to
people who want to receive that
information well I mean let's go back to
that point um what makes news um news of
someone issuing a press release is
boring uh news of somebody saying um I
think you're a bunch of infidels and I
wish youd change your minds and become
Islam is ism is boring um so they do
something truly horrific because they
know that horrific things make news uh
you then have a problem um that's what
they want you to do I mean it's because
some Chinese philosophers said always
ask what your enemy most wants you to do
we always answer terrorism with what
they most want us to do we fall straight
into the Trap of doing what they want
but is it not our job well it's not our
job to do their job for him it really
isn't our job but what I do think is new
and this is in a sense the point where
where where we might discuss it um is
this is quite unlike like other forms of
news this is a form of when you're
covering a war you're covering a war uh
in this case you are a part of the story
because that's what the other side wants
you to be and in becoming a part of the
story you are as you said at the
beginning a part of the problem rather
than the solution and I just think what
I'm saying here is I think for for for
newspapers it is no good simply saying
we cover every story um because in the
first place you have as as as as um you
as we've been saying you have a decision
to make about how how intensiv you cover
it I mean do fly Hugh Edwards out to
nice which is what the BBC did um I mean
that's exactly what I'm sure I said
please will you fly Hugh Edwards out to
nce thank you very much BBC you've done
what you wanted to do we wanted you to
do um you have a decision to make as to
how intensively you cover the story but
I go beyond that really and say you are
now the story you are a part of what the
other side wants to happen so you can't
you can't just simply say it's like
another story okay Douglas do you agree
with that is there essentially a
synchronicity going on or a symbiosis
between Isis or groups like Isis and the
media are they are they kind of playing
into each other somehow yes they are I
mean we know the extent to which people
for instance in Isis use uh the internet
to see what their coverage is like you
know that day I mean there are there are
cases of this um so there's obviously a
synchronicity I think by the way the
whole thing plays into a thing which I
mean it's not just on this subject but
on any subject what is what is the the
normal routine in the media now in the
yeara of 24-hour news something happens
you need somebody to react to the
something then you need somebody to
bring on the story but every journalist
anyone who's ever worked in journalism
will know this you know get a call for
BBC CNN or something the Prime Minister
said this uh about this happening I
wonder if you'd call for this you think
well no usually uh um usually it's in
politics it's somebody calls for
somebody's resignation you know that's
another kick of the wheel The Story Goes
On a bit longer now they've been calls
to the resignation of this person after
this thing that's happened and so on and
so on so there is there is a there is a
momentum to all news stor keep pushing
it keep pushing it forward and the
reason why I mean personally I don't
watch the if you don't mind I'm saying
so the 24-hour news after any terrorist
attack because something terrible has
happened and one doesn't learn very much
about it by the you know the presence of
said you know major reporter standing
some miles away you know from the scene
or the the best one not to be too
light-hearted about it but it wasn't the
terrorist you remember that when the
that Russian submarine went down Don
some years ago uh the BBC ended up
renting a helicopter to fly over the sea
uh to show a bit of sea and and then
then on air it turned out that they
weren't allowed to fly over the bit of
sea which the submarine was under
because the Russian authorities had
ordered a a blockade over the airspace
so the BBC just an enormous expense had
covered a bit of sea like the bit of
[Laughter]
sea
um okay fair enough but for wise I mean
don't you think there is a need I mean
because I think the point that we seem
to be dancing around here a little bit
is not that one shouldn't cover it or
give them attention it's about the kind
of attention you're giving them and
instead of giving them catchy little
nicknames how about doing some real
hard-hitting reporting that looks into
Isis as being a symptom of something and
not necessarily A Cause I mean I think
what we need to understand is that uh
there is two Wars and the the other War
the media War really is strategic for
both alqa and Isis that everything they
do in order to really I mean get
attention everything they do is they
want to instill fear and terrorize the
public whether you're talking about Iraq
or Syria or Libya or Western societies
and many ways we have to make decisions
how much coverage we give to the I mean
certain particular attacks I mean let's
remember I mean again I'm I'm I'm taking
you away from uh I mean the the media
itself that initially Isis is not really
interested was not interested initially
in carrying out attacks against the far
enemy against Western Societies in fact
Isis differs dramatically from alqaeda
because the basic focus of Isis is on
the near enemy whether you're talking
about Iraq or whether you're talking
about Syria or Libya or Egypt the reason
why Isis has decided to attack Western
Target because again because it
perceives basically the US Le alliance
with France and and uh uh the United
Kingdom so in this particular sense we
need to talk about why Isis has decided
to attack certain Western Target what
has happened you know what what's the
Strategic mindset of both Al and Isis
we're not doing this and in many ways I
mean if you if you follow and in fact
Isis is delighted by the coverage it's
getting whether you're talking about
Brussels or Paris or Germany or other
places so what's the alternative though
I still don't really have a feel for
what the alternative is I think we we
have to we have to talk about these
attacks but think about it I mean you
you covered the attacks in Paris I mean
nonstop for days several days every
single television stations I mean the
the the amount of coverage is
overwhelming it's just overwhelming I
mean you you covered it yourself and
this is exactly what Isis wants you to
do you're basically playing Into The
Narrative of Isis because Isis basically
is appealing to the base Isis is
motivating inspiring the base and also
Isis saying well look we have capacity
we have capacity to strike at the heart
of European societies it's also as a
recruitment technique and we know in
fact we have covered after every attack
basically increased number of young men
and women who tend to migrate to these
particular groups whether you're talking
about Syria or Iraq or Libya well what
do we do about it Reas because we have a
responsibility to our viewers and our
readers too and they do care about
terrorism they do think it's important I
mean care important yeah well I mean you
know we can all sit here with our lofty
Ambitions and be like oh they don't
understand it's not strategically
important but they people they do feel
it's important it's ghoulish it is a
particular sort of horror deliberately
designed to appeal to the ghoulish um
voyerism in the viewer that's what
they're doing now the question is how do
we respond to it and is a good
reasonable question I mean I I I think I
think I think myself that it as I said
before it's quite unlike any other story
we're not just covering the story we're
covering a very particular sort of story
and and and I just think it's incumbent
upon the media represented here um to to
to to ask themselves now how do we
exercise self-restraint because it is
about restraint I mean at the moment
it's I mean an American president is
building his presidency on terrorism
it's ridiculous how on Earth do we draw
back from in the state of of of of of
this obsessiveness um I think what it's
worth that that that that the Press
regulatory bodies such as they are and
the professional bodies ought to be
preparing protocols um conferences
discussions about how we react to
terrorist incidents they ought to be I
mean most news organizations I probably
including yours do have a sort of
protocol I mean leamor tried to restrain
naming terrorists um a lot of press
organizations have ways in which they do
handle this and they are moderately
effective
but I I can see a situation which in
which almost the government of the day
says not not censorship it says look you
guys you're really you're really a part
of the problem you're a
menace I mean you asked I mean of course
the public apologies do you want to
finish y I mean the question is to what
extent does the coverage the extensive
the overwhelming The Addictive coverage
really produce certain public reactions
to what extent in many ways we are
pulling pouring I mean gasoline on the
Raging Fire just at the end the last
year of Barack Obama the American public
I mean we have surveys about this the
American public was I mean almost majori
opposed to any kind of American
intervention other in Iraq or Syria and
in this in the space of about four or
five months there was a marked basically
difference in the reaction of the
American public a majority of Americans
basically I mean the views changed
dramatically as a result of the media
coverage of the barbarities that
basically taken place against Americans
well I don't know whether there was a
causal link between how the media
covered particular events and the change
in the American attitudes about
intervention or whether somehow I mean
the the barbarities themselves brought
about the the uh change in the American
and and I think you rais an interesting
point there and I wonder Douglas if you
could sort of expand on that a bit you
know there is there an argument to be
made we've heard president Donald Trump
come out and say we're not covering
terrorists enough and to all of us who
work in news I think we were like you
must be taking the piss was probably the
first reaction and then they provided
this list of you know I mean various
attacks in Europe many of which in fact
we hadn't covered because they were
incidents where maybe one person was
stabbed and because the threshold is
probably quite high at this stage for it
to become a you know leading a a news
broadcast but you didn't do enough on
Sweden did
you but do you think there's an argument
to be made on the other side that we're
not covering it enough that we're trying
to sanitize it that by not showing the
images as you said um that by not sort
of you know go going over every single
incident well can I firstly the um the
Press already the media already does a
fair amount of editorializing before you
even get to the discussion we're having
let me give you one example um Isis
which is the subject of far's book uh if
you'd like to hold it up again uh no I'm
I've got I've got a 10% deal on this no
um uh Isis now now the the main
broadcaster here in the UK the one that
we all pay for the one that is I think
responsible for uh the fact that our
media is not as divided as it is in for
instance in America there's much to be
said for the BBC the BBC chose to not
use that term it's so-called Islamic
State uh as the BBC that's an editorial
decision it takes about the group I've
often said I keep on hearing the BBC
called the so-called Islamic State more
times I'll put my so-called shoes
through the so-called television um but
it's an infuriating editorial decision
which never they've taken before you've
even got to reporting the story that's
why you can speak to a lot of people in
this country who despite this uh what
we're talking about here as being an
over coverage still have very little
idea of what it is that Isis wants
because we actually don't have a lot of
that discussion because our broadcasters
and our press don't want to have a lot
of that discussion and so we go round
and round on the pornography of violence
I'd much rather we had those uh those
bigger and deeper discussions that meant
you that the people knew what was
actually going on with this group what
they actually want and what groups like
them want but just very quickly I've got
to pick up as well on this on this
mention about Sweden if I may because
this this actually does get to a core
divide that's going on at the moment I
do not enjoy the bation of American
Media I have to say I don't like the
fact that increasingly uh the are two
sides talking about each other but never
to each other uh and I think it's
enormously regrettable for democracy as
a whole um that said there is a specific
problem which the which the Sweden story
actually talks to now as it happens I've
just finished a book uh which uh which
far will be by agreement promoting any
moment no uh which comes out in May but
it's it's about uh the migration crisis
in Europe and I've been spending quite a
bit of time in Sweden among other
countries and there are now it's not
terrorism on a daily basis but there are
so many societal problems that have
broken out in Sweden in the last few
years and you very very rarely see
anything about it in the press and the
media in this country or in America and
I think that that that what happened in
this is emblematic of a problem so the
media doesn't cover the story okay you
could say well who cares about Sweden or
it's just you know it's just this but
the fact is that it's the non-coverage
of that of a very serious story and then
a sort of cack-handed reference to it by
the American president that is responded
to by the liberal media saying it's so
hilarious Sweden's just this wonderful
place where everyone's just doing Ikea
stuff all the time is a horrible
horrible deepening of the Divide may may
I just I I mean I'm glad you you have
mentioned Donald Trump and
what what what really worries me a great
deal U is not about whether we discuss I
mean the phenomenon of terrorism we
should uh I think the phenomenon of
terrorism is going to be with us for the
next 20 30 years is byproduct
globalization it's part of breakdown of
societies in the Muslim World
Afghanistan Pakistan Iraq Syria uh
really what we are seeing in the west
here basically the
reverberations of the breakdown of the
state system in many countries I mean
this is just that's why I said it's
nuisance what what alarms me a great
deal is when I hear Donald Trump and
other politicians in the heart of Europe
collapsing terrorism with the refugees
collapsing terrorism with migration
collapsing terrorism with Islam and this
is and then you have a big existential
problem in our hands this is really
where Western politics now this is the
question this is the challenge how do
you separate how do you delink the
phenomenon of terrorism which is
dangerous in a limited way right limited
way I mean I call them really organized
Networks criminality why do we treat
terrorism different than the mafia why
do we invest terrorism with existential
cultural overts I mean the overwhelming
majority of Muslims I mean I this cliche
have nothing to do with Isis or alq the
over overwhelming majority victims are
Muslims whether in Iraq or Syria or
Libya or Egypt or Afghanistan but this
is what we really are going round and
round the question to what extent does
Donald Trump now use and he has used the
question of Isis
very effectively politicians in the
heart of Europe Douglas itching just
it's slightly off the topic but just it
reiterates the point I was just trying
to make which is that an absence on one
side creates something on the other and
this is a very good example the uh I
said it for long time if if your entire
media says that Islamic extremism has
nothing to do with Islam you will create
a movement that says it's all to do with
Islam and all Muslims must be involved
in the same way as if you pretend that
no migrant uh into Europe is ever going
to be anything other than the most
brilliant PhD student you will create a
movement that says they're all
terrorists I mean that is part of the
problem see but but but but but you you
you how do you answer the problem I come
back to ch's question I mean you you you
you've got a peculiar thing here you've
got um a requirement which all
intelligent liberal people think say um
which is to cover responsibly world
events um uh there are lots of terrorist
incidents in the Congo Uganda or Nigeria
or Sudan we just don't cover them it's
darkest Africa we don't cover them
doesn't matter how horrific they are we
don't cover them because we've got this
thing we cover terrorists and terrorists
is something that happens to us in our
country not in their country now if we
give terrorism what I still think is a
ludicrously exaggerated extent of
coverage um and and I I wouldn't go as
far as you Douglas and saying you know I
want I want to show pictures of the dead
bodies as well um in order to enrage the
population even further should yeah I
mean I just I I just want to suppress
that because unless you suppress these
sort of tabloid images it's very
difficult to get a conversation going
about what is happening in Nigeria or
Sudan or somewhere else um and and I I
do come to a point which i' never ever
thought I would in my life with saying
that I just some somehow think the
concept of censorship self censorship
but censorship has got to be part of
this debate and it has not become that
yet but let me ask you this then Simon
quickly and then I will open it up to
the floor but just this idea of one
thing we haven't touched on tonight is
the idea that we all work in a business
it is a for-profit business okay and
media is
changing by the day people go wherever
they can for their information it's not
no one buys you know the the methods of
consumption are changing and people can
go to where they want um they don't have
to come to us and I guess if we engage
in the kind of self-censorship or
whatever you want to call it because I
do think you raise a lot of fair points
what if people stopped reading the times
or stopped watching CNN or stuff because
I guarantee you if they're interested in
reading about it and they want to know
more about it and you're not covering it
they will change the channel or change
the website well I mean that that's not
an answer there a question is that's why
I'm the moderator and you're I I didn't
think I I didn't think the answer to the
points we've been making is is you might
lose money um I'm oldfashioned enough to
think that that journalist journalism is
actually about a certain sort of ethic
um in which you try and find out what
the truth is you do not exaggerate the
truth you present the truth um you don't
become a part of the story you stand
back from the all these things old as
the Hills uh always nagging at our
shoulder is the Sun or the tabloids or
Hurst or whoever it might might pull it
so I mean all these these These Old
gorillas always saying oh give us a
better story give us a better story make
more more money that way um the reason
why I'm proud of Journalism is is is is
for 100 years enough journalists have
said I'm not going down that route I'm
going down the route which simply says
what I think to be the correct way of
looking at the world I'm going to go on
doing
that okay this seems like a good point
to open it up we've got um two ushers
with roaming microphones so you put up
your hands and if you're in the gallery
space there's a standing microphone
there um I'm G to ask you guys to keep
your questions first of all if you don't
mind standing up while you ask your
question and if you can keep them as
succinct as possible and I'm going to
take them in bunches of three and
distribute them to the panelists so
let's start with you um I wanted to just
encourage you all to keep the word
perspective in mind I'm really with
Simon on this that I believe we've
reached a train wreck Confluence of
media politics and
money a station like CNN has now found
that is economically viable for them no
matter what happens one plane crash one
terrorist attack to have 80 million
panels that go on around the clock
asking people their
opinion there are wildfires in Chile
there are deaths in Congo there's Ebola
there are scientists working on things
and I really encourage you to just
deliberately give equal weight to other
stories and the people who want to read
about is us all day long will do so but
most of us won't excellent point is
there a question do you agree it's a
matter encouraging you to keep doing
what you're doing but just don't give
them the oxygen okay thank
you thank you very much um the question
tonight is whether does the media react
to terrorist events I would like to ask
is the real problem that GE strategic
Powers overreact to terrorist defense so
for example one thing in this debate
that I find very dangerous we haven't
mentioned terrorist attacks on India for
example we forget after 9/11 there was
there was an attack to destroy the
parliament of India to try and wrench
Kashmir out of the Indian State and
start a civil war on the subcontinent we
have the Mumbai attack of 2009 which
though had a smaller death count than
most of the wars of the 20th century
could have led to a war between Pakistan
and India
which is the greatest location where
nuclear exchange take place a war of the
vastly destructive um potential could
take place due to smaller events in the
Middle East for example are we seeing
the disintegration of Syria and Iraq
into its sectarian elements and
terrorism is a symptom of the problem
and not actually causing the problem so
for example um before 1914 the
anarchists and their bombs could kill
some thousands of people but it was was
then the assassination of arute
Ferdinand and then the overreaction by
geopolitical powers that then caused the
massive problem that we now have okay
and another
one I think it's clear that nobody is
arguing for censorship it's about
restraint and against sensationalism but
if it's
sensationalism I would argue that or or
ask isn't it isn't that really a threat
in terms of our reaction because it uh
uh it feeds an agenda even here of
people who want to um curtail civil
liberties but the real threat now is
that there is someone in the United
States behind the president who believes
in chaos um I dread the next uh uh
attack on the United States which is
bound to happen happen because we really
might see a genuine threat to democratic
institutions given the people in power
today isn't isn't that a threat okay
another good question and I'll take one
more and then I'll distribute these to
the
panel should we have one from the
gallery yes
sorry I thought I was safe um I suppose
I think we've talked about this little
Simon you referenced it we are talking
about Terror through a lens of terrorism
that happens to White westerners and um
Douglas you asked the question earlier
like how would we stop it and I think
the simple answer to how we stop it is
that we do appear to stop it whenever it
happens to Muslim people brown people
black people look at what happened in
Canada and I know it's very easy for us
all to say nobody changed their Facebook
profile to a Canadian flag and says just
we Canada but I I we need to have that
discussion why are we as the media
complicit in not covering terrorism that
happens to people of other MH faiths
okay so I'm loving how many American
voices I'm hearing
tonight a rare this is our night ladies
okay so let me start then by asking you
Simon the first question very
interesting one is the real problem the
media or is it geopolitical powers that
are overstating the terrorist threat for
their own strategic purposes well
firstly I mean terrorism is not new um
but it's new in the of global sense that
it we're now experiencing it we are we
are completely obsessed with it it's
it's the dominant Narrative of defense
policy for instance which has nothing to
do with terrorism to my mind um I mean
soldiers have seized on it we can we can
handle terrorism rubbish and they just
can't um so it is new in that sense but
it's it's it's it's not new in other
sense I mean people have always been
mesmerized by extreme violence and um
people have employed extreme violence in
order to get their message across um and
to that extent giving them what they
want is what we've been doing all I'm
saying is that I think now it's it's a a
different order um the fact that we
don't cover certain terrorist incidents
or certain terrible situations was not
the same thing is is is is a different
point the point about terrorism is it
depends upon the Press that's my point
but I guess you know the the gentleman
who asked the question was also posing
the idea of you know are people like
President Trump using the fear of
terrorism or the threat of terrorism to
try to push through their own agenda
well I mean this is one of the many
reasons for not not exaggerating the
threat of terrorism I mean as as as the
question here said um do you really want
to allow um a real a massive drive
against civil liberty in the in the
cause of somehow suppressing terrorism
they're not connected at all but but
they're used by Within any society there
are elements in government that want to
clamp down on things and the clampers
down have seized on terrorism I mean our
own home office have seized on terrorism
um as a reason for clamping down on
things now that's giving into terrorism
if anything was for wise I I wonder if
you might pick up on that because I do
think that relates to the second
question uh from the woman who was
talking about you know her very real
fears about President Trump and I think
there was a not so covert message uh
illusion to Steve Bannon there as well
um but I I wonder if the idea of
sensationalism plays into this in a much
more Sinister and dangerous way not from
giving into the terrorists or giving the
terrorists what they want but in this
case to giving politicians perhaps what
they want thanks Helen for your question
I mean to come back to Simon uh in his
uh introduction has said uh correctly so
that uh terrorism in terms of numbers in
terms of uh substantive uh casualties
even though every casualty matters human
life matters it doesn't matter whether
you're talking about even though six
individuals get killed in the United
Kingdom and and the United States every
year these are human beings matter but
we're talking in terms of the
institution of War six people people are
six people as opposed to 60,000 or
80,000 people by the way um 85% of
casualties of the casualties of
terrorism take place in five countries
uh Syria Iraq Afghanistan Pakistan uh
Nigeria and Libya uh so the overwhelming
number of casualties and and uh we we we
hardly tend to make the distinction but
to come back to the point Simon said
that the way we react the way we respond
allow terrorist basically to win in
terms of first of all we terrorize
ourselves we terrorize our public to a
great deal as a result of you know
addiction to this particular coverage
and also undermine the Democratic Values
the democratic values and that's exactly
I mean what Usama Bin Laden and zaahi
and Abu Bakr bagdadi and and all of them
want they want to undermine the
democratic values and let's come back to
I mean Donald Trump Donald Trump during
his campaign he talked about a ban
against Muslims an ideolog collapsing
terrorism with Muslims that is you're
talking about 1.6 I'm not defending
Muslims here but any you cannot collapse
a a limited phenomen with a particular
civilization again playing into the
hands of alq and Isis and what have you
again another element of the question I
mean think of the way we covered as you
know before the the Paris attack there
was a major attack in Beirut in Western
beut in which 200 people were killed it
received har and and this had any
attention I was there hardly any
attention in in this in beut I was in
Beirut too and there was a great deal of
controversy why BBC and CNN does not
really respond to the an attack that
killed hundreds of people where in Paris
again very it tells you a great deal but
that's a different situation but to come
back to the central question terrorism
really the way we react the way we
respond to terrorism basically has
tremendous significance to the terrorist
and also to the values not just Donald
Trump populist movement throughout
Western societies now are using and
abusing terrorism they're collapsing
terrorism with migration with refugees
with cultural entities in order to
basically I mean for political ends
undermining the democratic values in
Western societies and Douglas I mean you
know the third question I thought was
really interesting as well because it
touches on an issue that we haven't got
into very much tonight but because
semantics matter the very definition of
this word terrorists that we Bandy
around so freely uh but which I think
means many different things to many
different people um it has become
synonymous with uh Islam somehow in the
minds it has been falsely collapsed as
you have said in the minds of many
people to the point now where an
American man goes and if he's white and
takes uh you know an an AK to his
nearest shopping mall and or goes into a
African-American church and kills 12
people he's not called a terrorist he's
called deranged or disturbed or you know
and I wonder Douglas if you know if you
have any thoughts on the idea of how we
appropriate the the sort of how we use
this term terrorism and who we choose to
call the victim of a terrorist attack
and who is just the victim of a of a
lone wolf or I mean this if I may just
make two points this very quickly one to
the lady up there I mean I don't think
we should beat ourselves up too much
about the coverage of terrorist attacks
that have a proximity to where we are
this always happens after a terrorist
attack now people say you know why says
you know why have you got so much
attention on Paris and less on Beirut
it's because Paris is Paris and Beirut
is Beirut and Paris is near us and most
people feel more kinship and they've
probably been to Paris and more people
have been there than they've been to B
Rude I mean you can always play this
game it's regrettable but it's not it's
not only us you know in our country that
feels like that um when something
happens near you it's it's of more
import to you than if it happens far
away and sadly the Middle East feels far
away most people and so of course that
that's going to be the case we might
regret it but it's not unnatural that
that's that's the way in which it's the
things are covered secondly on this
things as it were about motivation
I there's another thing that happens now
after any terrorist attack which is it
happened
recently of um what was it there's a
sort of Graphics that get sent around
Facebook social media Twitter all that
kind of thing you know the number of
people killed each year by I know
lawnmowers versus the number killed by
terrorists you know everyone has a great
chuckle you know you're more likely to
be killed by your toaster than you are
by a you know and all and that also that
also sort of skews the whole debate
because you know I don't deny those
stats in certain countries by the way
they always tend to be you know things
like uh how many people have been killed
in America by terrorism since the 12th
of September 2001 you know no no yeah
but the point is is this but this is so
so you go you know it always starts from
a certain date that that you know helps
the statistic as it were because if you
did it 24 hours earlier you've got to
put in 3,000 more people and so on same
with Paris they don't pass around the
Paris uh death toll statistics on the
same amount because they're they're not
not not as sort of giggly uh for a bit
um but again I know like I don't deny
that a toaster can be dangerous or a
lawn mower but if there were a movement
deliberately making dangerous toasters
you know or deliberately miswiring
lawnmowers to make sure they kill their
owners you know I'd want to know about
it and so would you and and that's what
we're dealing with movements that
actively want to do this and so of
course there's a there's a
disproportionate emphasis on that
because that's what matters for us um
first of all uh you're absolutely
correct proxim proximity matters uh uh
cultures matters societies matters
Nation matters but the question on the
table here is that the way we report on
terrorist incidents color and influence
public opinion if we have a
comprehensive I'm not going to use the
term objective if we have a compreh
comprehensive and well-rounded coverage
of terrorist incidents in the world the
public will get a particular I mean
objective understanding that terrorism
is not just you're not the only one
because you're blonde doctors you're
being attack terrorism is a global
phenomenon most of the victims are
really Betis or alipo or what have you
point one point two again statistics
matter doulas again since we we are we
we're worried about how Isis and Al
manipulate terrorism so when we tell a
British citizen here that the risk of
being killed by a terrorist on annual
basis is 1.5 million per year that
you're basically you risk of being
killed by a ter is 1 in .5 million this
matters sure that is there is there is I
mean the risk is there is a risk but 1.5
where in the United States is 1.9
million and so matters final point on
this one to come back the reason why CL
claresa the debate matters a great deal
because the people now when I say
populist movements and uh you know
identity driven movement you're talking
about people now who believe in The
Clash of civilizations Steven Bannon and
the people around the gang around our
president americ subsp to the idea that
there is a clash between the west and
the rest and the rest is body Islam and
the whole idea and this is matters so
when he says Trump you're not reporting
on terrorism claresa enough he's saying
to you I want you to report on this I
mean fault line the Islamic fault line
the Muslim fault line because he and the
ideologues behind him and other people
here in the heart of Europe subscribe to
this notion that is a clash of
civilization there is no such thing
there is a clash within civilizations
Isis and alqa people and I've spent
really years I met is about the war with
them this is basically I mean it's a
symptom what we're witnessing here and
that's what we're not telling people
this is a war within civilization it's
not about war between Islam and the West
okay let me take some more questions
because we're got so much good stuff
we're talking about uh
yes so um I think it's unrealistic to
ask media to stop covering terrorism in
general since way before this era of
terrorism if it bleeds it leads has kind
of been the way journalist has been
journalism has been acting um however
Simon did bring up a point in that it
terrorism is unique in that media
themselves are implicated in the story
the question is do you think that as a
result media should not be more
self-reflective and actually bring this
as part of the story to the public that
they themselves VES are a part of the
story and educate the public on that
role that they're playing as well as
educate the public on how they too could
play a role by doing things like posting
on social media and Fanning the Flames
even further okay good
question who oh yes sorry
hi hi then um my question is instead of
talking about whether they should be
deprived or not deprived actually talk
about what oxygen we're actually giving
them because a lot of the words and
terminology that we use sometimes
they're very unclear for example we use
the word Islamic extremism but what does
Islamic extremism mean I mean somebody
here might think well if it's Islamic
extremism it has to be something to do
with Islam on the other side the
terrorists are actually getting happy
because they paradoxically when you say
Islamic terrorism to them they think oh
it must be it has to do something with
us and so we have to retaliate because
they've got got this paradoxical mind
that if they talk about us exclusively
just about us that it has to be
something wrong with them because
they've already been brainwashed into
thinking whatever they say is a
conspiracy theory and so when we sort of
exclusively Point them out instead of
just saying that they're terrorists they
actually get fuel for that so my
question is is it really about whether
we should or shouldn't give them oxygen
and more about what oxygen are we
actually giving them okay
and yes hello oh hi um to the extent to
the extent that the media shows
restraint is that there not a danger
that social media will fill the vacuum
fill it with lies and then the the
official media has got a decision does
it now report on what the social media
is saying or does it still restrain
itself it's a very difficult tradeoff
how where does the panel think that the
line should be drawn good question okay
well let's start Simon with the first
question which was directed to you and
this was an interesting idea should the
media bring this whole question of media
complicity and or you know media's
responsibility and media's role to the
public and engage in a sort of dialogue
about their role The public's role is
that a productive way of of dealing with
this conundrum somehow well I mean yes
it sort of answers the last question as
well which which is and this is new how
do we handle social media I once we had
a nice Monopoly I mean the journalism
profession uh and the big media
organizations had it all their own way
um now we're being challenged by new
means of communication
and uh and we're in trouble or regarded
as being in trouble I personally think
editing is going to come back I think I
think they're going to be regulating the
social media Google and Facebook are
going to be under huge pressure to to to
moderate what they're doing um we're in
a period of Anarchy at the moment so I
think it'll change and that'll answer
some of these questions at least but I
mean um yes whenever there's a horrific
incident I mean I and other people
usually write an article saying exactly
the same thing please don't OV
exaggerate the implications of this
incident um spitting in the wind but at
least you feel you're saying what you
believe um and I I I don't know I just
think I think that I mean I
agree nothing's going to change if it
bleeds it leads um on the other hand um
when and I come back to this point
there's a particular thing about a
terrorist story which is unlike any
other story it is not like our normal
stories where we're standing back and
we're putting up a camera and witnessing
something we're actually we're actually
a part of the story and to that extent
the only way of handling it I think is
is as you suggest to try and explain
that we're a part of this story it's not
dissimilar though in the US for mass
shootings where some reporters have
elected not to give the names of people
who perpetrate these because it's again
you know and we've had incidents where
Shooters have actually gone so far as to
murder people on live television or on
webcams to try to you know and then you
do have this incredibly uncomfortable
relationship where the media is part of
the story well I mean I I I would would
like I would like in these C in these
peculiar circumstances for there to be
some sort of of of of um collect
collective discussion as to how we ought
to restrain ourselves um I don't care
what the word sens I mean censorship is
editing you know I'm an editor you're a
censor uh that's not the point the point
the point is how do we decide how we
cover a story do we cover it at Noam or
do we cover it a little or do we cover
it just enough what are the words we use
to determine how we cover the story this
is this is The Daily Bread of newspapers
is not the Daily Bread of social media
yet but I do believe it will one day be
that okay for the second question was
about you know is it less about giving
them oxygen to breathe or what kind of
oxygen we should be giving them and
talking specifically about this idea of
Islamic terrorists as opposed to
terrorists and and whether that
conflates the issues and I guess I would
just piggy back on with that question
isn't terrorism already such a loaded
word in terms of semantics well I mean
words matters uh uh not for our
president
uh um they matter a great deal uh for me
as an educator I mean we we the first
thing we say Precision Precision facts
realities for 8 years Barack Obama never
used the term uh you know Islamic
radicalism or and he was criticized heav
very much and he lost the argument in
the United State because he was
basically portrayed as a weak president
a president that does not have really
fire in the valy that he on he really
lost it in terms of public opinion and
and uh Trump played on this very very
well uh but again to come back to what
Trump and Company are using now Islamic
radicalism it's a code word it's a code
word in the eyes and ears of millions of
Muslims it means Muslims he's collapsing
uh you know Muslim extremism why not
call it Muslim
extremism what's wrong with this term
but to Bannon and to the ideologues
behind the president Islamic radicalism
and Islamic terrorism basically canote
the fact because Islamic the term
Islamic is is is connote civilization
think we use the term islamist I use the
term islamist islamist is basically we
we have invented a term which really
doesn't mean anything I use the term
jihadism again jihadism is a very loaded
word because the institution of jihad is
like the institution of just war in
Christianity that is you can really
activate the institution of jihad when
aggression when you are with aggression
but can I ask the first do you honestly
think it would get better as it were in
the Islamic world for want a better term
if you called it Muslim terrorism no
extremism Muslim extr terrorism but what
do you call it mus are you saying we
should call it Muslim extremism
extremism absolutely or just extremism
no no they in in in the world of Islam
they use Muslim extremism you have
Muslim you have Christian extremist you
have uh Jewish extremists you have black
extremist whatever this is a neutral
term but the term Islamic the term
Islamic in Islamic Studies is basically
connotes a civilization that is Islamic
Studies Islamic culture Islamic and here
you're adding Islamic that's how it's
seen and the reason why Barack Obama and
his administration because they were
concerned about how basically the term
resonates with the
musliman this word terrorism and someone
say what is Terrorism I mean I terrorism
is a word for a method violence it's
it's it's like a gun okay a Muslim gun
Muslim terroris purpose of the of of the
gun that is Terrorism is to gain
publicity that's my problem the question
is I mean the question is there is
extremism there's a great deal of
extremism in the world of Islam Today We
agree on that I mean that's and we can
explain why there is a great deal of
extremism in the world of Islam and yes
Al and Isis are an integral part of
Muslim extremism why because they're
using and abusing certain values and
norms and doctrines in a very narrow and
we we all talk about that I mean I
highlight all that please Isis a
history it's in paperback it's
uh good
booksh but I I no I'm seriously I worry
again to to reiterate when the president
of the United States uses a loaded term
and this is the kind of oxygen this is
the kind of this is cultural
overtones because that's exactly what I
mean what they want to hear they want to
in the eyes of Abu Bakr Al bagdadi and
the rest basically they are defending
the Islamic umah they are standing up
against the you know decadent West the
aggressive Colonial West and what Donald
Trump and Company are saying we hear you
we're also standing up for the west and
this is a kind of a clash of
civilization Douglas I want you to
respond to that but I wonder if you can
do it also in the context of answering
the gentleman's question which was about
this idea of we can editorialize and use
this you know nice bit of sophistry that
kind of takes the edge off of things and
makes us all feel quite happy with it
but are people then just going to go to
social media where they can hear the
real tough talk and you know cut through
the bull As Americans would say um can I
answer that first minute um we live in
an extraordinarily perilous time in
general with information in this regard
at the moment and let me give you uh two
very quick examples that don't have
directly to do with the thing we're
discussing tonight but which which speak
to
um the way in which you can now pump a
lie or a rumor straight into the
mainstream news is far more woring than
I think people are aware of and let me
give you two very quick examples um 18
months ago uh when a conservative party
donor who is disgruntled that he hadn't
been given a place in the cabinet for
his cash
donations um releases a biography of the
then prime minister making the most LD
possible claim with no source that any
newspaper in this country would would
stand up and publish on the back of
about something the Prime Minister was
alleged to have done as as an
undergraduate Ox for those of you who
know I'm not going to repeat it um but
uh that was said in a book published by
the author at the author's expense the
disgruntled former friend of the prime
ministers he managed to pump that claim
directly into the system of the British
press and it was on the BBC and
everywhere why because the papers know
that if they don't repeat the allegation
that is baseless and so on it's all over
the internet and all their readers are
going to go over the Internet let me
give you another example of that a claim
made before or around the time of the
late recent election no after the
election before the inauguration of
Donald Trump about uh uh uh allegedly
compromising uh information from the
Russians without saying any speculation
about where it comes from again a story
which normally a newspaper would not be
able to run because there's no source
for it there's nobody backing up the
claim is put into into a website which
then is so lurid that it goes all around
the world and before you know the times
of London is reporting the lurid thing
that nobody ordinarily would pick up
because it's on the net and they know
that all of their readers are going to
disappear onto the net otherwise so if
that can happen with these sort of groty
you know innuendo stories we have to
consider how vulnerable we are in
general to much more serious stories now
and I think it I think that that
dividing line has become very very
dangerous Ju Just very quickly to
respond to the point about FS about this
I I'm I'm a bit more skeptical than you
are about this because I mean over three
presidents now since 911 they've all
taken a different tag and the response
has pretty much been the same nobody
likes to remember this but what was the
first thing that George W bush did as
president after 911 he went to the
Islamic Center in Washington read his
favorite bits of the Quran and insisted
Islam is a peaceful religion this has
nothing to do with Islam okay no and
everyone of course subsequently you know
nobody gave him credit for it but that
that was George W bush uh uh Barack
Obama refuses to say the ter Islamic
extremism when um a man shouting Al
Akbar at forood uh kills a dozen uh uh
Marines it was described famously as
workplace violence and um and so this
thing comes up what are they holding
from us why are they lying to us we can
see what it is why are you not saying
that the guy shouting Allah is greatest
wst gun people down maybe doing it for
theological reasons and you start to do
the contrary thing and that's why you
now get as I say this this situation
it's the same thing as I say with
migration with European politics and all
this stuff the public AR on to nothing
when they're worried that the media was
holding some of this stuff back from
them as I mean Barack Obama was berated
at the UN by David Cameron for this it
was Cameron who said at the UN a year or
so ago you know it's not enough that you
say it has nothing to do with religion
you've got to admit it has to do
something with religion in order to deal
with it but but we are creating contrary
forces all the time at the moment
excellent point another round of
questions
sorry um hi there oh sorry should I wait
on no go for it okay um this is really
fascinating so thank you um I I was
curious we're obviously talking a lot
about the media and whether or not we
should you know talk about this or not
talk about this and where's the line and
blah blah blah and I wonder you know
we're talking about the fact that it's
really unlikely to be involved in a a
terrorist attack and you were saying you
know should we be asking them what they
want instead is not talking about the
solution or and what is what is the
solution should we just not talk about
it all and it'll all go away are we
inflating our own importance in all of
this maybe as well and we could stop
talking about it and it would still keep
happening probably just following on
from that um are we financing terrorism
by providing the oxygen of
publicity okay and number three okay
yeah uh hi the um Simon Jenkins position
is um incredibly plausible and and a
sort of desirable position for the uh
the educated Elite which was a phrase he
used but we here probably represent a a
vastly
disproportionate proportion of the of
the population at large and my question
for the panel is are we not in danger of
underestimating uh the reaction of The
Wider population that the educated Elite
is imposing some sort of self-censorship
and therefore creating
suspicion excellent question and if we
can keep our answ is a little brief do
do you want to start with that one Simon
because you look sort of inspired to
speak there are are we are we out of
touch I I I come back to something
Douglas said I mean I sense we are
everyone thinks the moment they're
passing through is some terrible crisis
and 50 years ago everything was so easy
and simple and straightforward Golden
Age um uh I'm not sure that's going to
be true but um it is clear that the
technology of of social media um coupled
with the particular phenomena we're
discussing tonight terrorism is
producing a kind of critical mix which
we find very difficult to handle I I
sort of believe because I'm an optimist
um that we'll sort it all out in the end
we'll muddle through somehow it'll be
okay I don't know why I think that just
my Outlook in life but do you think
we're out of touch I mean that's
basically what we're hearing this whole
conversation the is is is if if we don't
if we
don't my subscript what he's saying if
we don't cover terrorism big um people
won't trust us anymore uh and and that
that's a worry that that would really
worry me and the reason why they may not
trust us anymore or the reason why their
lack of trust matters is I'll get to
social media so there's there there two
or three new elements would play here
and I don't know the way through this I
just know that that that good
responsible media journalism ought to
stick to his guns it ought not to
exaggerate it ought to explain it ought
not to sensor it ought to explain but it
ought not to get um frightened by the
fact that irresponsible social media
doing other things and and and I do
think as I said before about about
Google and Facebook and all these other
social media activities I am convinced
that within 10 years time they'll be
properly regulated in some sense now
that may be an undemocratic thing it may
be an elitist thing I don't know but I
just think the the degree of of Reckless
irresponsibility you do see now with the
social media will be brought under some
sort of control okay for us do you want
to take the question about are we
financing
terrorism uh how uh I
mean I mean I guess the idea being are
we making money out of terrorism and
giving terrorists publicity in the
process I mean we know we we we think we
know uh where the finances uh you know
for Isis come from multiple sources
basically most of it uh in the region uh
in the greater Middle East and the
Islamic World whether you're talking
about oil in Iraq and Syria or gas or
criminal networks or donations from
certain countries in the wealthy uh Gulf
countries U also uh when musul fell to
Isis in the summer of 2014 tens of
millions of dollars were basically
hoarded by ISIS and you're talking about
Isis also uh selling oil and gas to
various uh networks in in Iraq and Syria
and these operations most of these
attacks basically take very little
you're talking about really uh not
hundreds of thousands of dollars you're
talking about tens of thousands of
dollars the big question uh to come back
to the oxygen the oxygen is basically
coverage uh it's cultural it's social uh
is inspiration motivation because that's
what Isis alq want they want to provide
motivation and inspiration for the base
they want Recruitment and what have you
final point about just come back to
about Barack Obama and whether Barack
Obama really refused to talk about Islam
in a major speech in the United Nations
Barack Obama made it very clear that
there is a major problem uh in Muslim
societies it was he was on record by
saying that this is a problem and in
fact when he invited Muslim leaders he
made more than once he basically
addressed Muslim uh opinion and said
that Muslim societies and Muslim opinion
makers must address this particular
challenge in Muslim societies I mean
again I I this is not being apologetic
or even politically correct uh Muslims
are the main victims of this bloody
thing sure Muslim societies are
basically have collapsed under the
weight of extremism
authoritarianism um you know broken
politics uh I mean people don't realize
whether you're talking about Isis or alq
Isis and alqa basically are a revolt
against both the political establishment
and the religious establishment in the
Muslim World there is not in my book by
the way I mentioned this
I there's not and and this is on the
record there's not a single a single
cleric darkas a single claric in the
establishment in the Muslim world that
has come in support of Isis not even
one can you imagine a fact a not even a
single Muslim clar from The
Establishment in fact I mean Abu Bakr
bagdadi and Isis the Revolt is against
the establishment he has called in order
to be had Muslim clars and again we when
we talk about Islam this is not to say
that there's not there are not major
challenges both in terms of
institutional and cultural and what have
you but it's one thing to say that and
another thing to say the bloody 1.9
Muslim 1 billion Muslims are responsible
for this thing they're not okay we agree
question number three we're going to
move on from this topic because we can
spend all night on it and it's a
fascinating one but I just want to get
to to the lady's question here which is
a really good question is not talking
about it an answer are we somehow in the
same way that everyone said when Donald
Trump finally came out and said radical
Islamic terrorism in the world looked
exactly the same as it did 5 minutes
earlier if we all just stop talking
about it is it going to make a
difference no the rhetoric matters but
obviously it isn't
everything president is finding out I
mean obviously you have to have a viable
policy behind it it's just that people
are quite rightly worried that an
absence of rhetoric or at least apparent
you know unwillingness to get right into
the Weeds on it is part of the problem
would suggest that you might not
actually want to be grappling with it
you know it's like I know it's like when
you speak to someone say how would you
deal with terrorism they say something
like you know we've got to deal with
poverty you think oh god well we'll do
that one soon I'm sure you know um um
and so I mean I mean it's it's so vague
as to be obviously meaningless um but
and I as I said and there obviously to
my mind not viable I mean you can't tell
people not to worry about something
that's very near them and my own view is
that for some time Americans have been
over heated about this and I think
Europeans have been slightly under
heated on it actually um but just very
quickly if I may uh uh there is a there
is um there is another reason we haven't
touched on yet but it is a Market Force
within journalism which we haven't dealt
with in the same way that there was a
period when the British police seemed to
find it most useful to be on Twitter all
day and uh finding people who' aired on
Twitter and people wondered why this was
the case and was saying well it's
obvious isn't it it's much nicer to do
that than to go and find robbers and and
things it's more restful uh in in the
same way uh for journalists it's much
nicer to report this sort the sort of
the cycle than it is to go onto the
ground and do the stuff and actually get
people interested in stories which they
didn't know that they would find
interesting I came back from northern
Nigeria the other week was researching
the the massacres that are taking place
there and you know there's not much
interest in this country in Nigeria but
part of the reason is that the British
press don't send journalists to these
places and so you get around say well
our journalists don't want to read about
Nigeria you know and so it becomes
becomes all part of it very very quickly
another very interesting point of this
phenomenon and the complexity of where
we are in it look at what became the the
the the the picture of the year at the
Press award ceremony the other day uh
the photograph of the Assassin of the
Russian Ambassador in Turkey standing
over the body of a man who was dead only
who was alive only seconds before
standing over that now that
was all over the press and we had no
problem with it it was a dead Russian on
the floor by a live heated when you
consider that the British press has no
problem doing that but
absolutely you know paron my French you
know needed to change its trousers over
reproducing a cartoon a few years
earlier you realize the sort of
craziness that we're in yeah you know
you're taking your life in your hands if
your publication publishes a cartoon but
everyone's got the dead body of the
Russian
everywhere okay we are drawing to the
end of our evening so we don't have time
for more questions I'm going to have
each of the panelists in a minute or
less please beginning with you Douglas
just summarize your thoughts and then
we'll do another show of hands and see
how you have all been I didn't you just
stop talking say I can't think of no um
no I would just say that that I think we
probably there's a fair amount of
agreement honly I mean I think we all
recognize that journalists have to
exercise a degree of restraint
uh and and I think we recognize that
there are times when journalists don't
and that that that we get it wrong um I
think we're all in agreement on that
there is one element of this by the way
which I mean always troubles me and
you've got to be careful about how you
say this but I do think the extent to
which the public uh uh um behave on this
also matters you know the the argument
that journalists always use is well it's
what the public wants and then you miss
the crucial thing of well what the
public aren't an entirely you know sort
of office you know collection of you
know um well I would use a anyway but
but insert uh um but you know the public
we know we are also uh um moral beings
and we can draw our own lines on this I
just do think that to an extent we also
all have to be aware of this do we click
on the you know do we Google you know
when uh you discover that somebody's
emails have been hacked do we Google for
the Hacked emails and then all have a
great laugh about it because if we do on
that then we probably do on the other
stories as well good point FAS one
minute or less I mean I I I think
probably uh as doctor said not
disagreeing a great deal I my take on it
is that we need to give the context we
need to be proportional uh we need to
put the whole phenomenon in perspective
in comparative terms we need to tell the
audience all of us uh that uh this
particular phenomenon has particular
Roots uh that what we are seeing in the
west here basically are reverberations
of a great social and political evil in
the Muslim world and I think most
importantly um uh we need to show
resilience uh you know it's amazing
about the the I was in Beirut too during
the attacks what was it 2015 or 16 it
was the day before Paris uh 200 people
uh were brutally killed by ISIS in West
Beirut 2 hours later the city I mean
took care of the dad they buried the the
dad and the city 2 hours later I went to
the same place back to normal of course
deep scar but the city was able to show
resilience was able to in Paris I mean I
I was there in Paris I mean the city was
traumatized for 2 3 weeks I mean Paris
it and again the the idea of resilience
the idea and and at the end of the day I
mean I I think we're very harsh on the
media because we we need to talk about
the public fear is the greatest Beast uh
that and and and that's what I mean Isis
Al that traffic in fear and in this
particular sense how do you restrain
this particular beast that's the
question Simon oh all we have to fear is
fear itself famous phrase and
unbelievably true um I have nothing much
to add I mean I I we we mustn't be
afraid um they want us to be afraid we
mustn't be afraid uh My worry is and and
I think I do disagree to with my
colleagues here I think it's a massive
problem for the Press I just think we
have got to find whole new forms of
self-restraint and we haven't shown it
yet and I don't know how we're going to
do it but I just think it's it's got to
be done and and uh and I don't think
it's satisfactory to say well if we over
restrain ourselves the social media will
do it for us it's like saying I'm going
to go rob the bank because someone else
will do it if I don't do it um that's
not what we're about the best solution
however is is is not to go on talking
about it so let's go home well okay on
that note I'd like to get one last show
of hands uh those in favor of the motion
we give too much publicity to terrorists
raise your hands
please gosh you did a number on them
Simon and those and those against those
who do not believe we give them too
much and anyone still who doesn't
know yeah yeah I'm sort of with you guys
actually it is a very complex issue
thank you so much to our amazing
panelists in
[Applause]